a very warm welcome to all our viewers
and Anjali from simply learn and today I
will be showing you how you can install
the configuration management tool
ansible so let's have a brief about why
one would use ansible and what exactly
is ansible so if you consider the case
of an organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
ansible a small team of system
administrators can write simple codes in
gamal and these codes are deployed on to
the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
States so ansible automates
configuration management that is
configuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible
so here is my Oracle VM VirtualBox
manager I'll be using two systems
there's the node system which is
basically my client system and there's
the server system or the master system
so let's begin at a server system so
this is my master system guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one thing we must remember with
ansible is that unlike chef or puppet
ansible is a push type of configuration
management tool so what this means is
that the entire control here lies with
your master or your server system this
is where you write your configuration
files and these are also responsible for
pushing these chord figuration files
onto your node or client system as admin
required
crepes are ansible tool is installed now
we need to open a ansible horse file and
there will specify the details of our
node or kleine machine
so this sir ansible horse pile as you
can see here the entire file is
commented but there's a certain syntax
that you'd observe for example here we
have a group named web servers under
which we have the IP addresses or
certain hostname so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this grooc basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the IP address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the IP address 192
point 168 point 2 point 11 once you have
typed in your IP address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for a client machine so all
communications between the server or the
master system and the client or the node
system takes place through SSH SSH
basically provides a secure channel for
the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the routes password and that's
it we are done
so now we save this file and go back to
our terminal
so now that our hosts file is written
the next thing we do is we write a
playbook the playbook is the technical
term used for all the configuration
files that we write in ansible now play
books are written in Yamma Yamma --ls
extremely simple to both write and
understand it's in fact very close to
English
so now we'll write a playbook the
playbook or any kodi neeya mel first
starts with three dashes this indicates
the beginning of your file next thing we
need to give a name to our playbook so
name and I'm going to name my playbook
sample book we next need to specify our
host systems which is basically the
systems at which the configuration file
or the PlayBook in our case will be
executed
so we'll be executing this a decline
machines mentioned under the group
ansible servers so we had just one
flying machine under it we will still
mention the group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
Klein machine which is root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
playbook
so becoming the routes called a
privilege escalation next we need to
specify our tasks so these are basically
the actions that the playbook will be
performing so you would have noticed
everything so far is aligned that is
named host motives have become and tasks
because these are at one level now
whatever comes under task will be
shifted slightly towards these right
although yeah Mel is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing so my first task is
install httpd which is basically a
Apache server so now my commands yam and
this will be installing the httpd
package
and the latest state of it will be
installed so that's our first task now
our second task could be running our
Apache service so name run httpd and the
action which is service
we'll be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd and state must be started now
we come to a third task so here we
create a very simple web page that will
be hosted so create content is the name
of a task and the content that we are
creating here will basically be copied
to unknown system at a particular file
location that will provide a content
will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for all
our HTML files and that's it we are done
writing our playbook just save this and
go back to your terminal
before we execute the PlayBook or push
the PlayBook on to our north system
let's check these syntax of our playbook
so the command for doing so is
and if everything's fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
PlayBook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the playbook to
unknown or the climb machine and that's
the syntax for doing so now as your
PlayBook is being sent over to the
client machine you can see that first
the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
ok because this does not need to be
changed and next task was running httpd
now although our system had the Apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were ok
now everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible
you have all kind of information
available here regarding which all tasks
were executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything's fine here we can
move on to a node system and we'll just
go to a browser so if a playbook has
been executed here what should happen is
that the httpd service must be in the
running state and the web page that we
created should be hosted so let's just
type localhost and great everything's
working fine so our web page is
displayed here so we come to an end for
our installation and configuration video
for the configuration management tool
ansible if you have any doubts please
post them in the comment section below
and we'll definitely get back to you as
soon as possible if you liked this video
please hit the like button also
subscribe to our channel if you have not
yet this is anjali signing off see y'all
next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here